[Music]
how is another mejía greeting you with his
brief informative today is wednesday june 16 they are
trying to bring
the quark back to las vegas after being closed
for more than three years this park near
maryland and charleston closed in
2018 due to  to a high increase in
crime but now leaders are
asking area residents what they
hope to see in the renaissance of the
park some of the renovations
include a special area for pets
different sections with
gym equipment as well as gates with a
security code to enter  the city will
meet to discuss the future of this
place soon
the bay vince vaughn and
berlin organizations are offering a drive-thru of
diapers and feminine hygiene supplies
for families in the valley
this event will be from 9 am
to noon
davis bernie located nearby  from the third in
ideal and farc football if you need diapers
or wipes you can register at babies
brownie point or heretic  prior to the event
and here are some
coronavirus vaccination clinics
around the valley for this week
there will be one today inside the
firehouse located near
charles range tomorrow it will be at kerry park they
will suffer saturday afternoon
there will be one  from the retiree center
had the shots they will be given on a
first come, first served basis no appointment needed
and now we turn to the
weather forecast we will continue with these
high temperatures reaching 115 degrees by today
there will be a cloudy sky for the night that
will extend until the  Thursday the heat will
not go anywhere since for this
weekend on Father's Day the
temperature will be at a maximum of 102
degrees have a nice day I am Héctor
Mejía and this was your brief informative
edition in Spanish
[Music]